je suis ici aujourd'hui pour vous faire
part de mon parcours
j'avais 15 ans quand on a dit que je ne
pouvais pas être mécanicienne et ce
malgré mon stage de 3e réussi en
mécanique automobile ou lycées jean
peyrègne à marseille j'avais 15 ans
quand près d'une dizaine de garagiste
m'ont ri au nez quand je suis allé les
démarches et avec mon cv
ma lettre de motivation et mes
recommandations à la recherche d'un
contrat d'apprentissage en mécanique une
fille ça fait pas ça
c'est ce que certaines personnes m'ont
dit quand on ne le faisait pas
comprendre indirectement mais si une
fille ne fait pas ça une fille ça fait
quoi
donc c'est avec ces informations que je
devais trouver mon saint graal le projet
professionnel
ma voix à force de tourner en rond dans
ma tête et sans le brevet des collèges
en poche j'ai donc atterri dans l'une
des premières classes de mission de
lutte contre le décrochage scolaire à
marseille dans le quartier de la
paternelle exactement je n'étais pas
plus avancés sur mon projet
professionnel et c'est à cela que
servent et cette classe établir élaborer
son projet professionnel et en tant que
fille
j'avais deux options le sait après vente
ou le siaap et petite enfance
et là ce fut l'électrochoc ce n'est pas
ce que je voulais faire pendant 40 ans
c'est donc avec les informations que
j'avais à ma disposition que j'essayais
de trouver ma voix et je me suis orienté
vers des études où l'on accepterait en
tant que fille et en tant que décrochage
scolaire j'ai donc atterri vers un bep
secrétariat
en apprentissage toujours mieux pour moi
qui m'ennuie vite à l'école deux ans et
l'arrestation de mafieux de patrons plus
tard ce n'est un secret pour personne
puisqu'il est passé aux infos à la télé
je vous passe le passage des prud'hommes
je me retrouvais avec ce fameux bep en
poche et dans ma lancée
je continuais vers un bac pro
secrétariat et puis un bts assistant de
gestion pme pmi
puis à moi la route chine et le cdi bien
sûr cela ne correspondait pas en tant
qu'assistante rh et interlocutrice
privilégiée des salariés
j'étais en première ligne du mal être au
travail en plus du meeting
bien sûr au bout de deux ans je quittais
mon emploi en bénéficiant d'une nouvelle
option à laquelle les salariés pouvaient
prétendre
la rupture conventionnelle c'est donc
libéré délivré que je repris mes études
grâce à une v ap une validation d'acquis
professionnelle j'avais j'avais besoin
de comprendre l'humain de mettre des
mots sur des maux
j'ai donc intégré la fac d'économie et
de gestion de marseille
toujours en quête de réponses sur le
monde du travail et les enjeux de
pouvoir est ce que vous connaissez la
différence entre la poule et le cochon
c'est une question que nous a posé un
professeur en l3 et bien la poule à la
pointe sont neufs et a fini son travail
et le coach en lui et finit en déconne
et et bien un bon professionnel est un
professeur
neil impliqué comme une poule et non pas
concernés comme un cochon suis je trop
impliquée par l'épanouissement au
travail pour me sentir bien et la
question que je me suis posée pendant
des années c'est donc en quête de
réponses que j'ai alterné phase
d'apprentissage et fassent d'emploi pour
trouver des réponses toujours jusqu'à
intégrer le master de recherche et
professionnels du laboratoire d'économie
de sociologie du travail à aix en
provence
en parallèle des questions que je me
posais sur le monde du travail et auquel
j'ai essayé de répondre par des études
en management des réorganisations et des
ressources humaines
j'avais besoin aussi d'être dans
l'action
la théorie oui qui correspond à la
simplification de la réalité mais la
pratique est l'action aussi l'égalité
est un sujet qui me tient tout à coeur
que le bien-être au travail
d'ailleurs pour moi le bien-être travail
passe par l'égalité ou l'égalité
professionnelle mène au bien-être au
travail
une fois qu'on a débroussaillé les
préjugés qu'on se recentre sur sa
singularité et comme fait sauter les
stéréotypes de genre on y voit plus
clair et être mason ou un homme sage
femme n'est plus un problème pour
personne
[Musique]
j'aimerais vous raconter l'histoire du
colibri
c'est l'histoire d'un petit colibri
donc il ya un feu de forêt et tous les
animaux de la forêt sans panique on va
tous mourir en maths on perd on a tous
brûlés et puis au dessus de eu un petit
colibri
ça c'est une cool hybride semble un
colibri un petit oiseau très petit qui
fait des allers retours entre le lac et
le feu et puis les animaux en le voyant
faire mais ils se mettent à éclater de
rire alors le colibri les entend et puis
va les voir ils angie mais qu'est-ce qui
vous
les animaux lui dise mais je crois
vraiment que tu va éteindre le feu à toi
tout seul et le colibri lord j oui mais
moi au moins je fais ma part le logo de
mon entreprise est un colibri faire ma
part c'est ce que je souhaite faire
humblement aujourd'hui l'action en
parallèle de la théorie toujours car je
suis aussi engagé dans un projet de
thèse dont le sujet vous l'aurez deviné
et l'égalité professionnelle et santé au
travail participe à une société plus
égalitaire afin que chacun chacune
puisse s'orienter sans préjugé est
devenu ma principale activité
mon activité consiste à ce qui n'existe
plus de métier réservé aux femmes ni de
métier réservé aux hommes vous pensez
que cela est inutile et pourtant france
il existe seulement 17% de métier mixte
vous pensez que cela est abstrait je
vous invite à lire la loi d'août 2014
sur l'égalité réelle entre les femmes et
les hommes
vous pensez que cela ne sert à rien je
vous invite à lire les nombreux rapports
études qu'il existe sur l'intérêt de
plus d'égalité professionnelle et de
mixité des métiers
vous pensez que cela coûte cher combien
coûte le turnover le manque de main
d'oeuvre
le mal être au travail mon activité
invite les organisations à s'inscrire
dans l'innovation sociale en répondant à
une réelle problématique la recherche et
fidélisation des talents
vous pensez que mon activité nous
concerne uniquement les entreprises et
les organisations
elle consiste aussi à ouvrir le champ
des possibles à s'orienter sans préjugés
si vous aussi vous pensez que ce n'est
pas normal que seulement 17% des métiers
sont mixtes qu'en france il n'existe pas
de métier réservé aux faits
ni de métier réservé aux hommes je vous
invite à faire votre colibri à ouvrir le
champ des possibles s'orienter en
fonction de sa singularité en dépassant
les prix jugés et pourquoi pas merci de
votre attention
[Applaudissements]